i
cómo
la pandemia empeorado notablemente la
presencia de las mujeres brasileñas en
el mercado del trabajo de hecho tenemos
en estos momentos el peor dato de
ocupación de los últimos 30 años en el
tercer semestre del año pasado sólo el
46% de las brasileñas tenían un trabajo
estable
además según cepal en el segundo
trimestre del año pasado la ocupación en
el trabajo doméstico remunerado bajo un
25 por ciento
muchos economistas recuerdan que la
presencia de las mujeres en este mercado
siempre fue muy baja y que la pandemia
sólo vino a empeorar esta discriminación
de género en el mercado laboral además
hay que recordar que en brasil las
mujeres ocupan los puestos de trabajo
que han sido más afectados por las
restricciones de la cuarentena como el
servicio doméstico el comercio y los
servicios
ah
por la pandemia en costa rica el sector
de los hogares como empleadores sufrió
una caída interanual del 45 5 por ciento
en el empleo femenino entre abril y
junio de 2020 es decir hay una
importante pérdida de empleo de mujeres
en labores de asistencia del hogar según
la más reciente encuesta del instituto
nacional de estadística y censo las
ramas con mayor desempleo de las mujeres
son el comercio al por mayor y al
detalle y las actividades de alojamiento
y servicios de comida otras actividades
que suman al desempleo femenino son la
industria manufacturera y la enseñanza
la cantidad de mujeres que trabajan
actualmente fuera del hogar en costa
rica un país de 5 millones de habitantes
es de 616.000 un número similar al de
2011 es decir hubo casi una década de
retroceso en el empleo femenino la
encuesta también observa que de quienes
hacen teletrabajo en el país el 52% son
mujeres y que 3 de cada 4 de ellas
tienen hijos bajo su cuidado lo que
aumenta la carga aún más
[Música]
la comisión económica para américa
latina indicó que en 2020 la tasa de
desocupación femenina fue del 12% esto
implicó que 23 millones de mujeres
latinoamericanas se sumarán a la pobreza
y se perdieron así avances de una década
en materia laboral para las mujeres un
ejemplo de ello en méxico según la cepal
es el empleo femenino en el trabajo
doméstico que tuvo una caída del 30 y
3.2 por ciento en datos generados en el
país según la más reciente encuesta
nacional de ocupación y empleo del
instituto nacional de estadística y
geografía un millón 300 mil mujeres
dejaron de pertenecer a la población
ocupada entre octubre y diciembre de
2020 y a la población no económicamente
activa se sumaron un millón 900 mil
mujeres en ese mismo lapso por otra
parte el consejo nacional de evaluación
de la política de desarrollo social
indica que en el país hay 51.9 millones
de personas que tienen un ingreso
laboral que no les alcanza para cubrir
la canasta alimentaria y son las mujeres
y los indígenas quienes tienen los
ingresos salariales más bajos
[Música]